[Musique]
Benjamin Luc pour le
groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste merci madame la
Présidente il est des moments où il se
joue ici bien plus que de la politique
bien plus que la loi où se joue
finalement l'identité de la République
et l'âme de notre pays alors que
l'extrême droite vient d'annoncer avoir
engrangé une victoire idéologique
majeure et s'apprête à vter
l'immigration je ne peux pas je ne veux
pas croire chers collègu de la majorité
présidentielle que vous puissiez toutes
et tous cautionner ce qui a été fait
sous la dicté du gouvernement en
commission mixte paritaire cautionnement
pour les étudiants internationaux retour
de la préférence nationale
l'automaticité du droit du
sol familiale abandon des régularisation
par le travail volonté de réformer
l'aide médicale d'État en 2024 vous avez
cédé surtout et vous avez surtout
cédé le sujet mes chers collègues en cet
instant ce n'est plus la gauche ce n'est
plus la droite ce n'est plus la majorité
ce n'est plus l'opposition c'est le
serment
humaniste conclu avec les Françaises et
les Français en 2017 et en 2022 quand
des millions d'entre eux ont choisi de
faire barrage à l'extrême droite raciste
dans notre pays chers collègues soyons
collectivement dignes de la dignité des
Français je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Ares
[Musique]
mèes monsieur Lucas madame la Présidente
pardon monsieur Lucas ça vous faisait
moins de peine la semaine dernière
rassem nationale se lever pour vous
applaudir monsieur Lucas en plus d'aller
chercher les voies du Front national
vous mentez parce que dans le texte de
la C Y a bien réularisation
trillestion
bien des dans les C de
rtion et Monsieur Luc les de sénateurs
du rassemblement national V contre le
texte du Sénat voilà jour et aujourd'hui
Madame Le Pen viendrait courir au
secours de la victoire mais c'est pour
voir votre mine déconfie en ayant vé la
motion de Reet monsieur
Luc alors oui
oui nous prenons
responsabilités et Monsieur
lucz pas n'importe quoi grâce à l'action
de la première ministre et de la
majorité il y a des distinctions entre
ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui ne
travaillent pas mais cette distinction a
déjà été faite en 1988 par Michel rard
pour le
RMI je vous remerci monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous êtes
lamentable nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir de la part de ceux qui font
entrer des entiers du programme de
jean-mie Le Pen dans la
lo sont à recevoir de ceux qui offr une
victoire historique à l'extrême droite
rien ne vous oblig à convoquer une CMP
rien ne vous obliger à présenter ce
texte rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez cdé l'histoire vous regarde
elle vous
jugera merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur
Lucas s' vous
plaît
monsieur Lucas nous nous connaissons peu
mais moi je n'ai pas quitté la région le
Front national était fort pour me faire
réire ailleurs moi j'ai toujours battu
le rassemblement national je n'ai pas la
quitté la région des Haut- de- France
pour me présenter en
île-de-fance j'ai battu le Front
national à toutes les élections et vos
leç de morale républicaine je les
mettrai dans ma poche quand je faisais à
la tribune des clins d'œils et Madame Le
Pen la vérité à Monsieur Lucas c'est que
vous avez renoncé à parler au peuple de
gauche pour les protéger nous leur
parlons et nous les éviterons le
rassemblement
national je vous
remercie